[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo ihr Lieben hier ist Teil 2 der
wirklich spektakulären Geschichte hinter
dem Attentat auf Franz Ferdinand mein
Name ist Toni Heyer und bei mir ist wie
immer der Liebe Mirko Kasimir hallo
Mirko hallo Toni schön dich zu sehen wer
Teil 1 noch nicht gehört hat der macht
das jetzt am besten bevor er diese Folge
hat trotzdem für alle an dieser Stelle
nochmal ein kurzer recamp was denn
eigentlich bisher passiert ist also es
ist der 28 Juni 1914 mitten in sarahjevo
der österreichische Thronfolger Franz
Ferdinand ist zu Besuch in der
Hauptstadt von Bosnien-Herzegowina
eine Gruppe junger Männer von der
Geheimorganisation schwarze Hand will
ihn beseitigen dafür sind die Attentäter
vom serbischen Geheimdienst ausgebildet
und ausgestattet worden der 19-Jährige
gabrielo Princip hat das Attentat
initiiert unterstützt wird er von seinen
Kumpanen dem ebenfalls 19-Jährigen
nedel-coachabrinovic und dem ein Jahr
jüngeren Trifon grabic zur Gruppe
gehören außerdem der 23-Jährige Lehrer
Danilo Ilic und der 27 Jahre alte
Schreiner Mohammed mich mit baschiic
sabrinovic hat soeben am Straßenrand den
Zünder seiner Bombe abgeschlagen und den
Sprengsatz auf das Auto mit Franz
Ferdinand geworfen aber die Bombe
kullerte vom Verdeck weg und detonierte
am Boden
die Explosion verletzt zwei Menschen in
einem nachfolgenden Wagen und dazu
einige Passanten
cabrinovic will zumindest den zweiten
Teil des Planes korrekt ausführen und
sich umbringen er geht auf Nummer Sicher
er schluckt nicht nur das Zyankali dass
er zu diesem Zweck bei sich trägt
sondern springt außerdem noch in den
Fluss das geht aber auch gründlich
schief das für ein Kali so stellt sich
später heraus das ist alt und das wirkt
einfach nicht mehr so wie erhofft statt
zu sterben erbricht sich der Attentäter
und auch der Sprung in den Fluss erweist
sich als Reinfall sowohl wortwörtlich
als auch im übertragenen Sinn denn
caprinovic erwischt eine seichte Stelle
im Fluss das dürfte weh getan haben es
dauert aber nur wenige Augenblicke dann
ist eine aufgebrachte Menge bei ihm und
schlägt auf ihn ein
kurz danach sind auch Polizisten und
Geheimpolizisten vor Ort und können ihn
verhaften bevor er noch gewünscht wird
und Franz Ferdinand
ja da ist gerade eine Bombe auf ihn
geworfen worden heutzutage würden sich
wohl mehrere personenschütze auf den
Erzherzog stürzen um ihn vor weiteren
Angriffen zu schützen sein Wagen würde
ohne zu zögern mit Vollgas los Rasen um
ihn aus der Gefahrenzone zu bringen
der Erzherzog aber lässt seinen
Chauffeur anhalten er will wissen wie es
den verletzten geht
mehrere Minuten gibt er einen perfektes
Ziel ab für die Attentäter ist es eine
ideale Gelegenheit ihr Werk zu vollenden
und tatsächlich ist einer von ihnen vor
Ort und mit einer Pistole bewaffnet er
lässt aber die Gelegenheit verstreichen
wir später selbst sagt aus Mitleid mit
der Herzogin ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass das daran liegt dass er jetzt seine
Opfer die ja eigentlich umbringen wollte
also sein Ziel
so wirklich aus der Nähe betrachten
konnte und nicht nur dass sie schnell
vorbei rasen und er diese Sekunde nutzt
um sie zu töten ein weiterer Attentäter
also bekommt es mit der Angst zu tun und
der Erzherzog und seine Gemahlin sind
zumindest für den Moment gerettet und
Gabriele Prinzip der Anführer der Bande
der gegen Sandwich essen oder einen
Kaffee trinken ja oder keins vom bleiben
aber dazu kommen wir gleich gegen 10:30
Uhr erreicht der Erzherzog jedenfalls
erst einmal das Rathaus dort will der
Bürgermeister seine vorbereitete
Begrüßungsrede halten aber Franz
Ferdinand der unterbricht ihn
aufgebracht Herr Bürgermeister da kommt
man nach Sarajevo um einen Besuch zu
machen und wird mit Bomben beworfen das
ist empörend
ja gut aber sind wir mal ehrlich kann
man auch irgendwie verstehen seine Frau
Sophie versucht ihn zu beruhigen und
legt ihm die Hand auf den Arm das klappt
auch der Bürgermeister kann seine Rede
runterbieten und dann tja höchste Zeit
Franz und Sophie in Sicherheit zu
bringen oder die Stadt abzuriegeln
Truppen hereinzuschaffen die Straßen zu
räumen die Reihenfolge der Autos zu
verändern die Verdecke hoch zu klappen
die Fenster zu verhängen und auf einer
schnellen und vor allem nicht öffentlich
bekannten Router aus der Stadt zu
fliehen er hat es denkst du vielleicht
nee immerhin soll der Konvoi nicht den
geplanten Rückweg durch die Altstadt
nehmen sondern wieder auf dem Appel Kai
entlangfahren du meinst da wo er gerade
erst mit einer Bombe beworfen wurde ja
genau das klingt jetzt vielleicht
erstmal nicht ganz durchdacht aber das
ist eigentlich gar nicht so doof
immerhin rechnet ja niemand damit dass
er hier noch mal lang fährt und es ist
eine breite übersichtliche Straße die
Kolonne kann da durchbrettern und das
ist auf jeden Fall besser als ich mit
dem großen prunkautos in den engen
Gassen der Altstadt zu verhindern der
Rest ist aber kaum zu glauben und kann
nur mit einer Überforderung der
Sicherheitskräfte und dem unterschätzen
der Situation erklärt werden man wartet
nicht bis Truppen eingetroffen sind die
den Weg besser schützen können die
Reihenfolge der Autos wird nicht
geändert und man klappt nicht einmal das
Verdeckung zum zweiten Mal an diesem Tag
fährt der Thronerbe des Habsburger
Reiches in einem offenen Wagen durch
Sarajevo
eben haben wir erzählt dass sie die
Fahrtroute geändert haben um die
Altstadt zu vermeiden und um weiteren
Attentätern einen Strich durch die
Rechnung zu machen da gibt es nur ein
klitzekleines Problem denn niemand sagt
den Chauffeuren das ist eine neue Route
gibt wieder einmal zeigt sich welch
große Auswirkungen solche scheinbar
kleinen Fehler auf den Ausgang der
Geschichte haben können also ist das
doch alles gar nicht von der schwarzen
Hand geplant man könnte fast sagen es
ist einfach nur Zufall womit wir wieder
bei dem Sandwich werden dass wir am
Anfang schon angeteasert haben also
Gabriele Prinzip der holt sich jetzt
nach dem fehlgeschlagenen Bombenwurf im
Feinkostgeschäft Moritz Schiller auf der
franz-joseph-straße besagtes Sandwich
oder auch nicht ja oder auch nicht
vielleicht trinkt er auch einen Kaffee
an einem Tisch auf dem Gehweg vor dem
Schiller vielleicht macht er auch keins
von beiden sicher ist nur dass er direkt
vor oder in der Nähe des Cafés ist als
die Wagenkolonne des Erzherzogs von
appelkai in die belebte
franz-josef-straße einbiegt und das ist
ja genau der Fehler der eigentlich
vermieden werden sollte keiner sagt den
Chauffeuren Bescheid und sie bleiben bei
der ursprünglich geplanten Route anstatt
straight aus der Stadt rauszufahren als
jemand den Schoß für das Wagens in dem
Franz Ferdinand und seine Frau sitzen
auf den Fehler aufmerksam macht legt er
den Rückwärtsgang ein um zu wenden der
Wagen kommt direkt vor dem Schiller zu
stehen hmm nur ein paar Meter von
Gabriele Prinzip entfernt
und der der kann sein Glück nicht fassen
da wird ihm der Kronprinz nach diesem
gescheiterten Versuch quasi zum Kompott
serviert Prinzip zögert nicht er zieht
eine Pistole und schießt zweimal der
erste Schuss durch schlägt die Wand des
Wagens und trifft herzugehen so viel in
den Unterleib sie kippt zur Seite ihr
Kopf fällt Franz Ferdinand in den Schoß
der zweite Schuss der trifft Franz
Ferdinand direkt in den Hals
erinnert ihr euch was ich vorhin erzählt
habe also dass die Ehe zwischen Franz
Ferdinand und Sophie eine Liebesheirat
war dass sie eine glückliche Ehe führten
dass er seine Kinder liebte
hier ist was er unmittelbar nach den
Schüssen sagte
nichts bleibt am Leben für unsere Kinder
jetzt gibt es kein Zögern mehr der Wagen
mit dem Thronfolger Rast zum Gouverneurs
Palast Sophie stirbt schon auf der Fahrt
aber das wird man erst später bemerken
Franz Ferdinand lebt noch als man ihn im
Palast auf ein Sofa bettet es ist nichts
sagt er noch dann ist der Thronfolger
des Kaiserreichs Österreich Ungarn tot
und gabriello Prinzip nach den Schüssen
schlug der das zuankali und muss es wie
sein Komplize wieder erbrechen das ist
ja schon alt ist
er versucht daraufhin sich zu erschießen
doch eine aufgebrachte Menge hindert ihn
daran Männer prügeln mit ihren
Spazierstöcken auf ihn ein vermutlich
hätten sie ihn tot geschlagen wären
nicht kurz darauf ein paar Polizisten
zur Stelle gewesen um ihn zu verhaften
okay Toni bevor wir über die Folgen des
Attentats reden wollen wir noch was zum
Sandwich sagen du meinst den Kaffee der
oder keins von beiden
also die Geschichte wird heute meist so
erzählt dass Prinzip sich im Schiller
ein Sandwich holte oder bei einer Tasse
Kaffee gemütlich davor saß als eben der
Wagen des Erzherzogs praktisch direkt
vor seiner Nase hielt und dass das alles
ein purer Zufall gewesen sei in
zeitgenössischen Berichten ist aber
nichts von irgendwelchen Snacks oder
Getränken zu finden und das könnte gut
sein dass diese Details sich erst später
in die Berichte eingeschlichen haben die
sandwich-story z.B taucht erstmals 2001
in einem fiktiven Roman eines
brasilianischen Autors über das Attentat
auf und dann erneut 2003 in einer
geschichtsdoku auf BBC 2 deren Regisseur
sich auf Nachfrage nicht mehr erinnern
konnte wo er diese Information her hat
also das Bild eines Mannes der sein
Sandwich weglegt und stattdessen zur
Pistole greift das ist vermutlich nicht
ganz richtig das ist eigentlich nur ein
unbedeutendes Detail aber es zeigt wie
sich Geschichte und Erinnerungen ändern
können und wie wir oft der besseren
Story den Vorzug vor den genauen Fakten
geben das gilt auch für die Erzählung
vom überraschenden Täter der zufällig am
richtigen Platz ist und er sein Glück
kaum fassen kann denn das
Feinkostgeschäft Schiller liegt ja genau
an der ursprünglich geplanten und in der
Zeitung veröffentlichten Route des
Konvois
gut möglich dass er gar nicht überrascht
war als die Wagen in die Straße einbogen
sondern dass er genau damit gerechnet
hatte ja Mirko das ist gut möglich
ich kann mir aber vorstellen dass gerade
wenn du wie du auch erwähnt hast wenn
ich ein fiktives Buch schreibe über
diese Story oder auch eine Doku darüber
dreht dann suche ich halt einfach die
dramatischste oder die sage ich jetzt
mal bildlichste Story die das ganze noch
griffiger und spannender macht und da
passt halt geschmückt genau es wird
ausgeschmückt und da passt dieses Bild
wie der Typ da sitzt vor dem Kaffee und
eigentlich sich gerade irgendwie ein
Sandwich gönnt oder einen Kaffee und
dann zufällig die beiden direkt vor
seiner Nase halten das passt halt
perfekt in diesen dramatischen Strang
der Erzählung auch wenn es nicht ganz
stimmt Toni ich sehe schon du bist
wirklich voll drinnen in diesem Film
aber lass uns noch kurz über das
finsteres Sequel sprechen ja da hast du
Recht das sollten wir machen und an
dieser ganzen Story da ist nichts lustig
okay noch mal ganz kurz wir haben das
schon am Anfang des Podcasts gesagt wir
sind ein Format und kein history Podcast
und deshalb wollen wir uns in dem Fall
natürlich keine Expertise anmaßen
zurück zur Geschichte am 28 Juli erklärt
Österreich Ungarn als Reaktion auf das
Attentat dem Königreich Serbien den
Krieg durch gegenseitige
beistandsversprechen wird innerhalb
kürzester Zeit erst Russland dann
Deutschland dann Frankreich dann ganz
Europa und schließlich sogar die USA in
den Konflikt gezogen der Erste Weltkrieg
hat begonnen ein bis dahin
unvorstellbares industrialisiertes
Gemetzel die mehr als 10 Millionen
Soldaten und 7 Millionen Zivilisten zum
Opfer fallen
hätte es diesen Krieg auch ohne das
Attentat gegeben
vieles spricht dafür dass es
letztendlich ein willkommener Anlass war
es ist auf jeden Fall eine schreckliche
und sehr lehrreiche Geschichte und es
gibt da draußen jede Menge gutes
Material dazu weniger ein Podcasts und
Hörbücher hört und mit Englisch gut
zurechtkommt dann kann ich euch
wärmstens die Serie Blueprint vor
Armageddon von Dan Colin empfehlen die
ist im Rahmen seines Podcasts denn Karls
Hardcore history erschienen der sowieso
zu den Besten gehört was man so auf die
Ohren kriegen kann Mirko eine Sache
müssen wir aber jetzt noch erzählen ja
natürlich was ist denn eigentlich aus
den Attentätern geworden
der entgeht der Todesstrafe da er noch
minderjährig ist er wird zu 20 Jahren
schwerer Kerkerhaft verurteilt und jedes
Jahr am 28 Juni soll er durch dunkel
Arrest und hartes Lager an sein Vergehen
erinnert werden
1916 stirbt der antuberkulose auch
Prinzip wird wegen seiner Jugend nicht
zum Tode verurteilt sondern ebenfalls zu
20 Jahren Kaka und denselben
Verschärfungen wie sein Komplize
insgesamt sind 25 Mittäter mit
Verschwörer und Mitwisser angeklagt die
meisten werden zu langen Haftstrafen
verurteilt einer von ihnen war so zu
brilovic kam 1918 nach dem Zusammenbruch
Österreich Ungarns frei und brachte es
später in Titus Jugoslawien zum Minister
für Land und Forstwirtschaft drei
Mitverschwörer wurden zum Tode
verurteilt und am 2 februar 1915
hingerichtet
[Musik]
eine wirklich heftige Geschichte mit
noch heftigeren Folgen toni ist das
nicht eine gute Beschreibung für das
ganze Leben du wirst jetzt zum
Philosophen ich glaube wir machen mal
Feierabend für heute okay es wird wohl
besser sein für unser heutiger Ausgabe
haben wir unter anderem auf Artikel im
Spiegel der Süddeutschen Zeitung einen
Beitrag auf Mike der history.com die
Wikipedia und weitere Quellen
zurückgegriffen gut das war's dann aber
wirklich für heute schön dass ihr mit
dabei wart wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch
das nächste Mal wieder mit dabei seid
und natürlich wenn ihr euch bei uns
meldet also Feedback Kritik
fallvorschläge alles was ihr habt oder
wenn ihr einfach mal nur hallo sagen
wollt die Links wir uns erreicht die
findet ihr in den shonouts bis zum
nächsten mal eure Toni und eurem Öko